[Musique]
quand je serai mort ce qui m'embête
c'est que les filles auront encore les
yeux bleus sans moi quand je serai mort
ce qui m'embête c'est que les firont
encore aux éclats sans moi quand je
serai mort ce qui m'embête c'est que le
monde
tournera sans moi quand je ser Mor c'est
que l'amour se fera sans
moi quand je serai mort ce qui m'embête
c'est que les filles enlèveront leur V
sans moi quand je serai mort ce qui
m'embête c'est qu'elles feront des ha
et sans moi quand je serai mort ce qui
m'embête que le monde tournera sans moi
quand je serai mort ce qui m'embête
c'est que l'amour se fera sans
moi quand je serai mort ce qui m'embête
c'est que les filles iront se coucher
sans moi sans moi quand je serai mort ce
qui m'embête c'est qu'elles pourront
perdre la tête sans moi sans moi quand
je serai mort ce qui m'embête c'est que
le monde
tournera sans moi quand je serai mort ce
qui m'embête c'est que l'amour se fera
sans moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
h quand je serai Mor ce qui m'embête
c'est que les filles ne se porteront pas
mal sans moi sans moi quand je serai
mort ce qui m'empête c'est qu'elles
auront toujours d'embarras du choix sans
moi quand je serai mort ce qui m'embête
c'est que le monde
tournera sans moi quand je serai mort ce
qui m'embête c'est que l'amour quand je
serai mort ce qui m'embête c'est que
l'amour quand je serai ce qui m'embête
c'est que l'amour se
fera sans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi